spreads it now that the UK has
officially notified the European Council
of its intention to leave what's next
the next steps were agreed by all member
states years ago and are set out in
article 50 of the EU treaty the other 27
leaders of the European Council adopt
guidelines for negotiations with the UK
those guidelines can be amended
throughout for negotiation The ministers
in the Council of the EU also meeting in
an EU 27 former authorized the opening
of negotiations they appoint the
Commission at the EU negotiator and
adopt a negotiating directors on behalf
of the eu-27 the Commission negotiates
with the UK reporting back to the
leaders in the European Council and the
ministers in the council the European
Parliament is closely and regularly
informed for as long as the UK remains a
member of the EU it participates in all
European Council and council meetings
except when brazzers is disgusting after
the end of negotiations the consent of
the European Parliament is required the
deal is then ready to be concluded by
the council when the agreements entered
into force the UK is no longer an EU
member and the EU treaties cease to
apply to it find out more on the council
website
[Music]
you